election officials in Sri Lanka's
capital had a busy morning sorting out
paperwork from 35 presidential
candidates former defense secretary gota
Bey Rajapaksa is hopeful to lead the
Rajapaksa come back five years after his
brother Mahindra was voted out of office
given the problems being faced today in
economy security and sovereignty we have
a set of policies that can solve these
issues and we hope to implement them
this Rajapaksa successfully led the
government's campaign to defeat the
Tamil Tigers in 2009 ending a 26-year
conflict but some accuse him of
disregarding human rights allowing
extrajudicial killings and cracking down
on dissent during that campaign
questions have also been raised about
Raja Parks's eligibility with
controversy about his dual nationality
his main rival Sajit prema dasa is the
deputy leader of the United National
Party he has been nominated after years
of being sidelined by Prime Minister
Rana Vikram Singh her prema dasa has
worked with rural communities for many
years but will have to find out if he
can appeal to voters across the country
I'm in hurry - from what a path-breaking
revolutionary development program in our
country where the benefits are accrued
to all and not to an exclusive family
club incumbent President Maithripala
Sirisena is not running for a second
term
now priorities appear to have shifted
for many Sri Lankans
the last election was fought on bringing
change restoring democracy and human
rights analysts say it's different this
time round they are not talking about
rights they are talking about
development they are not really talking
about democracy per se in a sense
therefore you know it's almost as if to
talk about rights is irrelevant at best
and subversive it was around 16 million
Sri Lankans are eligible to vote in the
presidential election next month
people have to be smarter politicians
are servants not masters they come to
serve
as voters we expect someone who can
bring economic development to the
country and individual development
someone who can govern well someone who
is a doer not just pays lip service more
candidates are contesting the November
16th election than ever before but for
now Rajapaksa and prima donna have the
highest profiles that said there's
public discontent with broken promises
and a chance that establishment figures
may pay the price at the ballot box
Meena Fernandez al Jazeera Colombo